ok j'ai vraiment beaucoup beaucoup parlé
sur la définition
sur les définitions et sur
l'historique donc on va essayer de
passer moi je dis tout le temps ça mais
on va essayer de passer un peu vite sur
les méthodes
parce que c'est pas non plus ce qui est
plus intéressant pour vous c'est un peu
rébarbatif donc c'est juste pour vous
donner un peu une idée de comment on
fait là ta phonomie parce que c'est bien
beau tout ça mais comment est-ce qu'on
en arrive à l'écosystème d'origine
comment on en arrive à comprendre tous
ces biais bon voilà on va y aller un peu
rapidement ce qui est intéressant de
savoir
ce qui est intéressant d'imaginer c'est
que
la tafonomie concrètement
il s'agit tout simplement de faire de la
médecine légale sur une scène de crimes
qu'il y a
plusieurs milliers d'années dizaines de
milliers d'années centaines millions
d'années
pourquoi je dis ça parce que
on peut pour essayer de comprendre un
peu l'approche ta famille
imaginez notre site archéologique comme
une grande scène de crime dans laquelle
les tafodolistes
sont ici en tant que médecin légiste ou
police scientifique disons
[Musique]
chez les Américains si vous êtes adepte
des
séries policières
et nous ce qu'on va essayer de
comprendre c'est essayer d'identifier
nos suspects donc qui sont en fait les
agents téléphoniques responsables
de l'accumulation et de la modification
de notre ossement de notre assemblage
faut s'y faire
et ainsi que donc on a nos suspects mais
aussi
nos circonstances sur une scène de
crimes les circonstances de la mort vous
allez suspects de la mort ici ça va être
les suspects et les circonstances dans
le sens scénario
comment ce sont accumulés ces fossiles
donc on peut imaginer que l'État
phonomiste au final
ce qui est dans le petit encadré là leur
travail à eux c'est de collecter
des preuves sur
sur
sur un cas de meurtre
pas forcément black un cadeau de mort
2 milliers ou millions d'années
de produire des analyses
et de livrer
une liste de suspects potentiels ainsi
que de scénario probable d'accumulation
de la sauvage
ça c'est un peu le concept qui a
derrière la tafonie c'est un peu
notre travail à nous
mais comment est-ce qu'on peut avec
quelle méthode et quelle approche on
peut justement
identifier ces agents et c'est scénarios
on va rentrer un peu plus dans le détail
il faut savoir
non il faut savoir quand un phobie il
faut utiliser
plusieurs
prises de lecture plusieurs grilles de
lecture pour essayer d'arriver à mieux
reconstruire nos événements d'origine
d'abord on va pouvoir étudier
notre faune c'est-à-dire on a tous nos
fossiles on va essayer de les identifier
essayer de savoir
est-ce qu'on a beaucoup de carnivores
quel type de carte d'Ivoire on a sur le
site
quel type de bestiole on a au final
est-ce qu'on a beaucoup de springbok
est-ce qu'on a beaucoup de de koudou
tout ça c'est des antilopes vous pouvez
googler après si vous voulez le nom de
ces animaux
le sprick box c'est la gazelle à poche
dorsale
celle qui est ici donc est-ce qu'on a
beaucoup de coups doux est-ce qu'on a
beaucoup de gnou est-ce qu'on a beaucoup
de girafe d'éléphant
de zèbre
tout ça ça va nous donner déjà des
informations
ensuite on va pouvoir étudier
la ce qu'on appelle nous la
représentation politique
pourquoi c'est important on va le
développer un peu plus
mais en fait ça va nous permettre
d'identifier tous nos billets potentiels
de représentativité
on va le voir après
ensuite on peut étudier les profils de
mortalité c'est à dire la distribution
de nos individus selon leurs âges à leur
mort
après et ensuite et ça c'est la partie
la plus marrante c'est
les modifications de surface osseuse
et ça en général c'est vraiment ce qu'il
y a de plus informatif pour nous
parce que tout le reste est soumis à
énormément de biais
ok tout d'abord avant même d'étudier
votre
vous obtenez déjà des informations
d'ordre taphonomique selon le contexte
de dépôt dans lequel vous vous trouvez
ce qui est logique parce que si votre
assemblage osseux que vous étudiez en ce
moment au laboratoire provient
d'un site de plein air de type fluvio
lacus
il sera pas soumis au même contraintes
ta phonomique peut-être qu'un assemblage
osseux qui provient d'une grotte logique
en grotte vous vous attendez à avoir
beaucoup moins
d'intempéries
comme le
comme les grottes sont des milieux
plutôt stables en termes d'humidité
dans soleilment
et de température ce qui n'est pas le
cas des sites extérieurs et ben on va
avoir beaucoup moins d'intempéries
beaucoup moins de dégradations liées aux
variations climatiques donc ça déjà
c'est quelque chose à garder en tête et
à savoir on peut pas se lancer dans une
étude tafonomique comme ça à l'aveugle
sans savoir au préalable d'où provient
nos fossiles
ensuite donc vous avez votre faune
et vous commencez à étudier votre
et selon la composition de votre faune
pareil vous allez pas avoir le même
type de signal d'affronomique attendu
par exemple si vous avez
ce type de phone il y a une brune
associée aux phacochères des forêts
associés aux gala et
et au buffle
bon vous êtes plutôt sur un
environnement de type de type
plutôt tropical plutôt équatorial
bon c'est des bestioles qu'on trouve
aussi
dans des latitudes plus basses c'est pas
un problème
mais c'est quand même symptomatique
ouais
ben ouais disons ça caractéristique
voilà c'est au moins caractéristique
d'un environnement de type fermé c'est à
dire avec beaucoup de végétation un peu
un peu humide tout ça
donc là vous attendez clairement pas à
avoir
votre lion comme étant l'accumulateur
principal de votre assemblage voilà
c'est aussi simple que ça si vous êtes
au contraire face à un assemblage qui
est plutôt hétérogène avec des restes de
carnivores donc ça c'est ce qu'on a
beaucoup beaucoup retrouver dans les
sites Afriques du Sud et d'Afrique de
l'Est du pays au pistol
avec des espèces des espèces dominantes
comme look doux et le springbok
qui sont représentants de deux tribus de
bovidés différentes que sont les
antilopilis et les l'infini
deux tribus très très importantes parce
qu'elles explosent lors de l'entrée dans
le Quaternaire en terme de diversité en
termes de
domination du paysage tout simplement
pourquoi parce que ce sont en fait des
tribus
qui sont
adaptés au milieu ouvert et sec
donc après le grand événement
d'aridification qui a eu lieu aux
alentours de 2,6 millions d'années à
l'entrée du quaternaire et bah ces
tribus elles ont explosé parce qu'elles
étaient avantagées
d'un point de vue évolutif
elles étaient très très bien adaptées à
ce type d'environnement et ils ont
continué à s'adapter à ce type
d'environnement
OK
et ensuite
vous pouvez aussi faire face à des types
d'assemblage qui sont des types qu'on va
appeler Bodo spécifique donc c'est un
assemblage dans lequel vous avez très
très peu de diversité très peu d'espèces
différentes
voilà vous avez imaginons
90% de l'Est de springbok de petite
gazelles
quelques restes de de chacal à droite à
gauche et après
plein d'outils en pierre
plein d'artfacts culturels pas là
forcément vous êtes dans un cas
d'accumulation d'origine anthropique
parce que souvent
les oblides sont les seuls à créer
intentionnellement
Paléolithique supérieur Paléolithique
supérieur quand on sait déjà comment ça
bien Homo sapiens c'est bien installé il
a ses stratégies siégétiques déjà bien
en place et lui il va créer très
facilement des des assemblages de type
mono spécifique
n'oubliez pas
[Musique]
on n'a pas ce genre de type d'assemblage
donc voilà
et à savoir ça existe
donc on peut déjà commencer par ça donc
déjà vous vous rendez compte que déjà
avec trois types de
fautes différentes ça nous aiguille sur
l'écosystème d'origine et un peu tout
tous les processus qui ont pu avoir lieu
à la suite du dépôt de cette assemblage
OK
l'approche classique pour pour faire ça
pour étudier votre faute c'est d'abord
d'identifier
tous vos fossiles donc pour ça on a des
lieux
qu'on appelle des ostéothèques qui ou
des
collections de comparaisons donc qui
sont des grandes collections comme ça
avec
le plus possible d'ossement
du plus
d'animaux possible disons-nous disons le
but d'une ostéothèque c'est d'être le
plus exhaustif possible d'avoir le plus
de spécimens
le plus d'espèces représentées par le
plus d'éléments
ostéologiques également OK
je vais pas rentrer dans les détails
mais le but c'est quand on trouve par
exemple une molaire
du antilope savoir laquelle on va
prendre notre molaire et la comparer
avec toutes les molaires des autres
espèces pas bien sûr on fait pas ça tout
le temps parce que l'expérience vient
avec le temps et qu'après on est
facilement capable d'identifier
nos fossiles sans avoir
recours un recours sans avoir besoin
d'un recours systématique à une
collection c'est toujours bien d'avoir
une collection mais bon quand tu es sur
le terrain par exemple tu peux pas c'est
pas grave
voilà à savoir que beaucoup Dolores sont
en général non d'identifier parce qu'ils
sont trop fragmentés ils sont trop
petits trop isolés voilà on peut pas les
identifier mais on arrive toujours à
trouver au moins des petites techniques
pour au moins essayer de d'aller le plus
loin possible et c'est d'en tirer le
maximum d'informations possibles donc si
par exemple je reprends cet exemple de
cette molaire qui est isolée de bovidés
c'est parce que c'est bon
il y a beaucoup de similitudes
morphologiques chez les bovidés donc
c'est parfois difficile d'identifier une
molaire isolée bon bah je l'identifie
pas mais au moins je lui donne
ce qu'on appelle une classe de taille
est-ce que ça appartient à une toute
petite antilope genre un Dick Dick ou
est-ce que ça appartient gros truc style
élan buffle ou grand coup
ça c'est des choses voilà à savoir donc
voilà donc on utilise des tailles de
classe des classes de taille pardon on
utilise des classes de taille
pour classer nos spécimens si jamais on
n'arrive pas à les identifier bien sûr
après on peut prendre des mesures
sur les eaux
après tout arrive la partie redoutée des
étudiants mais aussi de pas mal de
chercheurs parce que ça ça a créé
beaucoup de débats encore aujourd'hui
c'est les unités de quantification des
ossements quand comment
on quantifie notre assemblage osseux on
a plusieurs unités de quantification
qu'on utilise très fréquemment les plus
usités sont le nombre de restes basiques
tout est dans le nom c'est combien
d'eau de fragments d'os tu as
même si deux ossements
appartenaient au même
ossement d'origine et que vous arrivez à
les recoller vous les comptez comme deux
ces deux fragments différents c'est des
nombres de restes ok ça c'est l'unité de
base l'unité basique ensuite vous avez
votre nombre de spécimens identifiés
donc là ça revient un peu sur le concept
que dont je vous parlais juste avant qui
est que la majeure partie de nos
fossiles bah malheureusement ils sont
trop fragmentés pour pouvoir les
identifier donc on a ce petit cette
petite unité de quantification qui
permet simplement
de savoir combien
de fragments on a réussi à identifier à
vous de situer votre identification
est-ce que elle se situe à l'espèce au
genre à la famille à l'élément
squelettique bon ça vous le préciser et
ensuite ça par une simple division à
simple ratio de Lisp sur NR bon ben vous
allez être capable de savoir combien de
pourcentages de votre assemblage vous
avez été capable d'identifier tout
simplement donc c'est bon c'est assez
pratique voilà
et ensuite là on arrive dans je pense
les deux unités de quantification qui
ont fait le plus couler d'encre il y a
énormément de d'articles scientifiques
débattent sur l'utilité sur comment
calculer
ces unités la première c'est le nombre
minimum d'éléments ce que l'éthique
ça par exemple si on reprend l'exemple
de vos deux fragments qui recolle
mais moi je me trompe ça vous donnera un
nombre de restes de deux vous allez de
reste
le nr est de 2 mais par contre si il
recolle et qu'ils appartiennent à
l'origine au même élément ce que l'été
et ben vous avez un Mme de 1 un nombre
minimum d'éléments de 1
et ensuite
vous avez le nombre minimum d'individus
et ça en gros c'est essayer de
comprendre
combien d'individus vous aviez à
l'origine
combien essayer d'estimer combien
d'individus
au minimum vous avez besoin à l'origine
pour expliquer
le nombre de risques que vous avez dans
votre assemblage
OK
prenons un exemple
déjà pour faire ça
de pousser ma tête voilà
déjà pour faire ça il faut avoir une
bonne idée
de la composition générale d'un
squelette de vertébrés
à savoir que cette composition est
fluctue selon les groupes les espèces
les familles etc mais voilà au moins
avoir une idée assez générale
prenons ce que je connais le mieux parce
que c'est ce qui est le plus représenté
sur nos sites archéologiques à nous en
Afrique c'est les antilopes donc on va
prendre un petit un petit peu vidé donc
là on a pris une bâche ok une vache
donc la vache elle a
tous humérus dans son squelette quand
elle est vivante nous aussi d'ailleurs
donc l'humérus c'est satoste ici c'est
l'OS de votre de votre bras
vous en avez deux à gauche un droit très
bien
imaginons imaginons maintenant que votre
votre assemblage archéologique se
compose
d'une partie proximale c'est à dire
la partie haute
une partie proximale
du mérus gauche
une diaphyse c'est-à-dire la diaphyse ce
qu'on appelle c'est la section du milieu
de votre
aucune diaphyse du virus droit cette
fois
et enfin vous avez une partie distale
c'est la partie inférieure de votre
partie dit ça
dure 3 OK
très simple votre nombre de restes et de
combien il est de 3 vous avez trois
restes ok très bien vous avez réussi à
identifier ces trois ils sont tous les
trois
identifiés comme des fragments du mérus
d'antilopes donc vous avez également un
ISP de 3 bon là il y a pas de différence
entre votre NR et votre NSP parce que
vous êtes super fort et que votre
assemblage est tout petit donc vous avez
un taux d'identification de 100% nickel
mais par contre si vous calculez votre
nombre minimum d'éléments
et bah là étant donné que vous avez une
diaphyse droit d'humérus droit et
indistal du virus droit qui peuvent
éventuellement se recoller et appartenir
au même élément s'il recolle ça veut
dire que de fait là vous avez
un fragment du merle rouge
deux fragments d'humérus droit qui
appartenaient au même
uberus droit vous avez un numéro
un numéro 3 ça vous donne un nombre
minimum d'éléments de 2
et votre nom minimum d'individus et ben
il est très simple étant donné que vous
avez un numerus droit numéro gauche il
vous suffit que d'une vache pour
expliquer la présence de ces trois
restes dans votre assemblage OK
exemple très simple
qui peut se complexifier notamment si on
essaye d'ajuster notre estimation en
prenant en compte la taille des éléments
mais aussi l'âge à la mort des individus
ainsi que leur sexe
par exemple
l'humérus gauche il pourrait très bien
appartenir à un sprintbox aucune petite
Gazette alors que votre humérus droit
qui se recolle vos deux fragments du
virus droit qui se
appartiennent à un élan donc
l'un des plus grands
la plus grande antilope d'Afrique et non
et bah là concrètement vous n'avez vous
avez toujours un de deux parce que vous
avez toujours que deux éléments deux
humérus un d'une petite gazelle et un
d'une grande gazelle mais par contre
vous avez un ennemi de 2 cette fois-ci
ce que vous avez de gaz une petite
donc vous pouvez ajuster comme ça
le problème arrive quand vous travaillez
sur des assemblages qui comportent 5000
20.000 restes bon là ça devient un peu
plus compliqué
de quantifier ça mais on le fait
toujours
représentation squelettique très
rapidement parce que ça vous intéresse
je pense assez peu
prenons l'exemple toujours de cette
gazelle vous voyez ici
un exemple théorique d'une gazelle
imaginons que sur mon assemblage
archéologique
j'ai
80 à 100%
c'est pas 100% parce que sinon il y
aurait plus rien d'autre mais disons
80% de représentation de la mandibule
80% de représentation
des eaux
je devrais pas dire représentation je
dirais plutôt survie
c'est ce qu'on
c'est une unité de quantification qu'on
utilise le pourcentage de survie
c'est en gros on rapporte
concrètement on rapporte notre nombre
minimum d'éléments ce que l'éthique
sur le nombre de cet élément
présent dans un squelette
fois le nombre d'individus minimum qu'on
a dans notre assemblage
OK
ça nous permet
d'estimer le pourcentage de survie d'un
élément squelettique
par exemple si j'estime que j'ai 10
antilopes on assemble âge
et que j'ai
lui émis mandibule dans cet assemblage
puis huit mâchoires
étant donné
que dans un squelette complet il y a
qu'une seule mandibule d'accord
on a qu'une seule mâchoire
et bah ça veut dire qu'on a 80 % de
représentation de mandibule
parce que sur les 10
individus on a huit mandibules donc 8
sur 10
ok si ça le pourcentage de survie bref
imaginons qu'on a ici
les mandibules et les os des carpes et
des tartes donc des mains et des pieds
et les métapodins
c'est les os que vous avez ici
qui sont sur représentés la question
c'est pourquoi
pourquoi
vous vous retrouvez face à une
si grande différence de représentation
ce que l'éthique
dans vos vidéos
pourquoi sur les 10 spécimens vous
n'avez pas dit squelette complet
pourquoi vous avez les mandibules qui
sont représentés à plus de 80%, qui qui
ont survécu à plus de 80%, les eaux de
l'extrémité des pâtes pareil et le reste
bof pourquoi
est-ce que
certaines parties spécifiques du
squelette ont été transportés
c'est-à-dire que certaines de ces
antilopes ne sont pas arrivés entières
sur le site ce qui pourrait amener à une
différence de représentation de certains
éléments du squelette
ou alors
est-ce que c'est dit carcasse soit
arrivé entière
mais elles ont subi
une ce qu'on appelle conservation
différentielle c'est à dire qu'elle ne
se sont pas tous conservés de la même
manière et c'est ça qui a induit le pied
pour évaluer ça on a des indices assez
spécifiques je vais pas les développer
parce que là c'est vraiment très très
pointilleux disons-le mais une des
méthodes classiques on va pas parler de
l'index
ou de l'indice de complétude plutôt
parler de la densité minérale osseuse
parce que c'est ce qui est le plus
commun
et le plus logique aussi
en gros
ce qu'on fait
c'est qu'on teste la corrélation entre
notre présentation osseuse et la densité
libérale de cette os
et si on se retrouve avec une belle
corrélation comme c'est le cas ici
corrélation positive ça montre
que les éléments les plus denses sont
les mieux conservés
logique vous allez me dire mais c'est
pas toujours le cas
et ça quand on a une corrélation
positive c'est dangereux parce que
dangereux on fait que de que
l'archéologie
c'est dangereux pour tes interprétations
pourquoi parce que
ça ça implique que les ossements les
plus fragiles
ils ont dégagé
et donc vous avez un billet de
représentativité ici
donc vous n'allez pas pouvoir
étudier votre représentation
squelettique comme étant représentatif
des conditions d'origine du dépôt
OK
ensuite profil de mortalité ici on va
s'intégrer s'intéresser à la
distribution démographique de notre
assemblage par exemple chez nos
antilopes on reprend toujours les
sentiments
chez les antilopes
combien est-ce qu'on a de vieux
individus ou de jeunes ou de bébés
ou d'adultes
ça
on le fait grâce notamment
aux usures dentaires
et
au stade d'éruption des dents par
exemple si vous avez une mandibule de
bovidés avec que des dents de lait
ou forcément c'est un jeune quoi OK
ça ça peut être prise en compte pour
calculer votre don minimum d'individus
bien sûr et ça peut vous permettre de
construire des graves ternaires comme ça
qui vont en fait étudier la distribution
démographique de votre population et
vous allez pouvoir la comparer avec des
distributions modernes
actuelles ou d'autres sites
archéologiques pour savoir un peu où se
situe
votre assemblage à savoir que si
auparavant vous avez démontré
l'existence
d'un biais de représentativité dans vos
éléments squelettiques bon bah déjà ça
ça implique que vous avez une
sous-représentation de vos individus
juvéniles pourquoi parce que bah ils
sont plus fragiles donc si vous avez une
corrélation positive comme ça sur votre
présentation représentation squelettique
bah ça veut dire que les éléments les
plus fragiles ils ont de grandes chances
d'avoir disparu donc vous n'avez pas
accès
à
tout le potentiel de votre assemblage
d'origine vous ne savez pas combien il y
avait exactement de d'individus
juvéniles à l'origine c'est pour ça que
c'est important de tester pour les
billets
voilà enfin la partie marron
donc d'où en tant que ta phonomiste ce
qui va également nous intéresser le plus
et ce qui va faire
[Musique]
couler le plus d'encre c'est
les modifications de surface osseuse
donc c'est tout est dans le nom mais les
modifications de surface osseuse c'est
toutes les altérations
et ça c'est intéressant parce que ça va
pouvoir nous donner énormément
d'informations sur le contexte de dépôt
et surtout les événements qui a pu se
passer avant ou après la mort avant ou
après l'enfouissement des
ossements
finalement on classe
les
les modifications de surface
selon deux grandes familles d'agents
afin de mec il y a les agents d'abord
inorganiques ou qu'on appelle abiotique
en français c'est tous les agents non
biologiques bien sûr qui vont pouvoir
[Musique]
impacter et altérer votre fossile par
exemple
les sédiments le climat ou l'eau
et ensuite vous avez tous les agents
d'ordre organique biologiques ou en
français on dit biotique
ici sachant biotique bien sûr c'est les
plantes les carnivores les rougeurs les
insectes
disons les invertébrés en général il n'y
a pas que les insectes les invertébrés
et les êtres humains tout ça ils peuvent
bien sûr bouger les fossiles les manger
les casser
et tout y compris vous allez le voir
tout de suite
donc ça c'était les âges les les
catégories d'agents et ensuite
on sait amusé pendant plusieurs années à
classer toutes les modifications de
surface selon des groupes morphologiques
ou morts ou groupes
voilà on va avoir par exemple la famille
la famille de du poli
du polissage donc tous les politiques
surfaces et l'abrasion surface le
branding l'arrondi le polish quoi
le peeling donc le peeling c'est plutôt
ce qu'on donnerait nous en français la
desquamation
c'est cet enlèvement de matière un peu
exfolier
on a toute la famille
qui est une grande famille
des fractures
et des cassures
toute la famille de la dissolution
corrosion tout ce qui est décoloration
et coloration toute la et ensuite les
deux plus grandes familles qui ont fait
également couler beaucoup de temps que
sont
les modifications circulaires ou subir
et les marques linéaires voilà et on va
un peu rentrer dans les détails de
chacun de ces groupes et c'est de
comprendre d'où vient
toutes ces modifications et qu'est-ce
qu'on peut en dire
alors les randings donc tout ce qui est
de l'ordre du Polyte surface d'ados
quand un os devient arrondi et poli
un peu brillant
ça c'est le résultat d'un processus
d'abrasion
ce qui est logique et ça peut être causé
par différents processus
que ce soit
abiotique ou biotique donc dans les
abiotiques on va bien sûr avoir l'eau
l'eau L'eau créée très facilement des
politiques en face
les transports sédimentaires aussi mais
le vent également et le piétinement
quand c'est piétiné un ossement comme ça
ça peut créer un petit un petit poli sur
les bords
dû au frottement en fait
des grains de sédiments à la surface de
l'os et dans les biotiques on va avoir
les carnivores qui vont pouvoir créer un
poli notamment
en léchant
l'os et à force de le lécher ça peut
créer un poli les hyènes font ça par
exemple
mais aussi la digestion ou la digestion
les c'est surtout les les cas d'idées le
font aussi
à moindre mesure mais voilà donc les
guides toute la famille des yènes ils
avalent les petits ossements et leurs
sucs digestifs sont assez puissants au
yen
il consomme beaucoup d'ossements
et parfois elles vont les recracher et
ça va créer ce qu'on va voir là des
patterns comme ça un peu ou là vous avez
une phalange proximale de bovidé moderne
et là vous avez tout un gradient de
l'effet de des sucs digestifs sur la
dégradation d'une phalange voilà
et ensuite bien sûr bah voilà les bio
turbations ou l'être humain peut créer
des polis
donc les caractéristiques les
caractéristiques d'un poli
donc c'est à l'arrondit des bords
saillants de l'os OK
et pour essayer de comprendre d'où
provient ce poli bar en général il faut
essayer de chercher
des
des modifications associées par exemple
est-ce que vous avez des perforations
dans sur d'autres parties de l'os qui
pourrait vous faire penser que
ça a été digéré ou des perforations de
type
traces de crocs qui pourraient vous
faire penser également que ça a été
consommé
ou est-ce que vous avez au contraire la
présence d'autres types de modifications
qui pourraient vous laisser penser que
ce poli est dû à l'eau à l'action de
l'eau comme par exemple une une
décoloration ou un dépôt à la surface de
de l'os c'est le cas ici de ces deux
ossements tout noir marron là
qui proviennent de la grotte de Coopers
en Afrique du Sud
ils sont noirs comme ça pourquoi parce
qu'en fait ils sont couverts de
manganèse et le manganèse c'est plutôt
associé à l'activité de l'eau parce
qu'en gros bon je vais pas vous faire
tout le truc mais
dans la grotte
l'eau va arriver du toit du plafond de
la grotte qui va se charger comme ça qui
va se saturer au carbonate mais aussi
parfois qui va ramener quelques dioxydes
que ce soit de faire de manganèse peu
importe et en terre collant c'est à dire
en tombant du toit de la grotte sur le
sol de la grotte sur laquelle il y a vos
ossements et cette eau peut venir
déposer à la surface de l'eau du à la
surface de l'os pardon du manganèse ou
du fer peu importe ce qui va donner ça
donc là pour ces deux
ossements
ou d'un poly qui est évident il se voit
bien audace poli
et ensuite
on a le morganèse
[Musique]
associé qui nous laisse penser que ce
poli du coup il est plutôt dur à
l'action de l'eau
voilà donc chercher un peu voilà
ensuite on va
parler un peu de corrosion
la corrosion en fait elle vient tout
simplement d'un processus de dissolution
de l'os la matière elle se dissout
et ça ça peut être du à plusieurs
processus chez les abiotiques on a
l'immersion dans l'eau ça peut faire de
sacrés dégâts
la corrosion de grotte donc ça c'est un
phénomène assez particulier qu'on voit
ici au milieu c'est vraiment très acide
parfois les sédiments de grottes sont
très très acide
dû à la nature des rushs environnantes
et de l'eau qui passe à travers bien sûr
mais aussi à cause des chauves-souris
qui vont
vivre en grande colonies dans les
grottes et qui vont parfois donc ils
vont pas parfois mais qui
vont en fait déféquer sur le sol de la
grotte et créer des couches ce qu'on
appelle le Guado donc le Guado c'est des
couches de
d'éjections de
colonie de chauve-souris ça c'est
extrêmement acide
et ça ça explose tout donc voilà ça peut
créer ce genre de truc et chez les
processus biotiques
les algues les champignons les bactéries
qui peuvent également créer ce genre de
de dissolution
chez la coloration décoloration je vous
en ai parlé un peu déjà le manganèse le
faire tout ce qui est dépôt de dioxyde
certains
phénomènes comme la décalcification donc
la décalcifications c'est un phénomène
d'érosion
qui va venir en fait
donner cet aspect crayeux à l'os c'est
en fait parce que
les carbonates
[Musique]
se dissout lors de la décalcification
donc en fait
il est il obtient cet aspect crayeux et
quand on l'a en main en général il
laisse aussi une poudre blanche sur les
doigts difficiles à manipuler
et on a également les activités des
champignons et des colonies de bactéries
qui peuvent créer de la disque
coloration
de la décoloration pardon
mais aussi également bon je vais pas
passer longtemps dessus parce que pour
le pliopiste ça nous intéresse un peu
moins parce qu'on n'a pas encore de
trace
évidente de domestication du feu mais
voilà le feu crée aussi une décoloration
progressive de l'os qui va tendre vers
le noir
et ensuite quand il est carbonisé et
ensuite qui va tendre vers le gris puis
le blanc lorsqu'il va être calciné un
degré très élevé
donc là on va être plutôt sur des
phénomènes qu'on va appeler de
de craquement je veux pas je vais pas
dire le craquage le craquage de l'os
là c'est exfolié il est esquimé c'est à
dire qu'il se
délite
en sous-couche
ça c'est ce qu'on appelle le processus
d'exfoliation et c'est en général
associé
au weathery donc à l'intempérisation à
l'effet d'alternance
de variabilité du climat
ou le cracking peut arriver par
compression sédimentaire et ce qui est
intéressant pour la desquamation le
peeling c'est que ça peut aussi être
fait par l'homme
c'est d'ailleurs une signature
téléphonique très très particulière qui
a été par certains chercheurs notamment
par white and Folken Fernandez ravaluz
et aussi pick ring et collaborateurs qui
ont été associés c'est
cette signature taphonomique en
particulier
le peeling donc la tesquamation sur une
partie très précise de l'extrémité d'un
os et en général des côtes
et selon eux associés à une activité
anthropique qui est de
casser l'os par flexion
en pression comme ça voilà
bon
il ne me semble pas que pour le moment
ça a été remise en question il y a très
très peu de travaux sur sur ce phénomène
de de desquamation en partie digitale de
certains ossements
bon c'est assez convaincant pour ce qui
est des côtes dans des sites assez
récents de la préhistoire
que faire
lorsqu'on retrouve de tels fossiles dans
des sites plus anciens est-ce que
d'autres
phénomènes peuvent conduire à la
création de ce genre de signature pour
le moment c'est pas trop connu on sait
pas
il faudrait qu'on conduise un peu plus
d'expérimentation pour explorer un peu
toutes les possibilités de desquamation
les fractures c'est un monde un bon
appart
la seule chose que vous avez à savoir je
pense c'est que nous ce qui nous
intéresse c'est lorsqu'on étudie les
les
types de fractures ça va être de savoir
si l'os a été fracturé cassé lorsqu'il
était encore frais ou est-ce qu'il était
déjà sec ok donc pour ça on va
enregistrer plusieurs caractéristiques
de la cassure qu'on observe
du plan de fracture qu'on observe sur
notre os on va d'abord enregistrer
l'angle est-ce que c'est tout droit ou
est-ce que c'est oblique
le type de fracture est-ce que c'est
courbé comme ça est-ce que c'est
transverse c'est à dire quasiment signé
quoi ou est-ce que c'est
ce qu'on appelle Vichy c'est à dire en
forme de W
et ensuite la texture du bord est-ce que
c'est
comment dire ça est-ce que c'est rugueux
où est-ce qu'au contraire c'est lisse et
doux le bord de fracture
toutes ces
variables ensemble elles nous apporte
une
indication sur
est-ce que là ça a été cassé quand l'os
était encore frais ou non voilà ça c'est
intéressant pour nous parce qu'on peut
avoir par exemple des fractures
dépend de fractures qui sont associées à
des types spécifiques de modification
par exemple des traces de dents
carnivores ou des traces de percussion
et du coup
on devient de fait en mesure
de pouvoir dire quelle est le processus
à l'origine de la fracture
voilà on enregistre voilà par exemple
aussi la longueur des fragments qu'on
observe la circonférence des eaux tout
ça
voilà je vais pas trop détailler
là-dessus
sur d'autres types de fractures ici par
exemple on a un beau phénomène de
compaction sédimentaire donc ça c'est
une observation moderne que j'ai faite
dans une grotte aux Zimbabwe où on voit
le dépôt en train de se former
dans lequel il y a des
ossements et dans lequel les ossements
sont en train de subir la pression
sédimentaires et là on le voit très bien
parce que ce tibia là
qui est bon il est pas horizontal
support horizontal
il subit la pression
du dépôt qui est au-dessus de sa tête et
il s'est complètement fracturé
ici dans le sens oblique par contre
l'os qui est juste au dessus de lui ici
lui il est un peu plus horizontal dans
sa dans sa position et là vous voyez
qu'il y a une partie d'idée peau qui
fait pression ici et qui commence à
créer une ligne de fracture
qui est de fait
logique idéale par rapport à l'axe de
l'os ça c'est l'effet de compression
et ça en grotte c'est assez fréquent
et souvent comme ils sont à l'intérieur
des sédiments
il ne bouge que très peu donc ils vont
se casser mais rester en place et c'est
et ça va conduire à retrouver des
fossiles de ce type là donc ça c'est un
fossile qui a environ 1,4 millions
d'années qui a été retrouvé dans une
toujours la grotte de Cooper en Afrique
du Sud et là vous voyez une double
fracture qui est due à la compression
sédimentaire l'os
était sûrement dans une position assez
similaire à celui-ci oblique sub
horizontal il s'est cassé in situ
mais il ne pouvait plus bouger
et par la suite l'eau est venu déposer
de la calcite ou que la calcite c'est ce
qui forme des stalagmites stalaggit
toute cette famille de spéléo hôtel
et qui va venir déposer de la calcite
dessus associée à du manganèse associé à
un poli donc ça c'est l'eau c'est le
boulot de l'eau
donc cette os il est
il est pas mal parce que c'est une
petite phalange et pourtant si vous avez
la grille de lecture nécessaire pour
comprendre cette os vous pouvez dire
c'est une phalange
alors dans mon souvenir c'est une
phalange de phacochère mais je suis pas
sûr
tu es du beau vide bon là comme ça
difficile de le dire vu que c'est
déformé c'est poli c'est un juvénile
parce qu'il manque la partie ici
articulaire bref c'est une Valence d'un
ongulé de taille moyenne qui a été
fracturé par pression
[Musique]
avec effet subsidiaire de l'eau qui est
venu polir l'os déposé du manganèse
et déposer la calcite à l'intérieur des
fractures de l'os ce qui fait que
maintenant on se retrouve avec un os que
celui-ci il tombera pas en trois
morceaux vous pouvez le tenir en un seul
morceau dans vos mains
parce qu'il sait cassé en étant dans la
possibilité de bouger donc voilà donc ça
c'est la compression sédimentaire
vous pouvez ensuite avoir voilà bah ce
qu'on appelle les encoches ça les
encoches c'est un type de fracture très
particulier qu'on retrouve sur les bords
de fracture là les encoches et quand on
a des encoches multiples comme ça c'est
plutôt associé à
l'action d'un carnivore qui est venu
casser l'ossement et c'est en fait là
les traces de ces multiples temps qu'on
voit qui a créé plusieurs autres de
pression et qui a créé ce type de
fracture
chez les Hominines
chez ouais les humains en général quand
il y a fracture
on a un phénomène assez caractéristique
qui va être
le double la double encoche voilà la
double encoche ici qui est assez jolie
ça ça va être plutôt associé à l'action
anthropique
OK
les traces circulaires et subir avec
aussi les perforations ah bah alors là
c'est tout un monde
en termes de processus abiotique vous
avez bien entendu
la corrosion de grotte c'est ce que vous
avez là ici la corrosion de grotte donc
ça comme on l'a dit juste avant la
dissolution qui est due à la l'acidité
élevée du sédiment de la grotte peut
créer une performance
là j'ai mis route je n'aurais pas dû
parce que ça va pas dans inorganique
mais dans organique donc ça c'est un
phénomène biotique et non abiotique
le trampoling donc le piétinement peut
créer des perforations ça peut arriver
mais aussi dans les grottes ça va être
plutôt
les chutes de roche
qui peuvent casser qui peuvent casser
des des fossés
mais nos perforations elles vont quand
même principalement être le résultat de
phénomène le biotique
savoir les carnivores surtout que ce
soit par digestion ou pas trace de crew
les invertébrés toute la tous les
insectes les gastéropodes aussi
[Musique]
quoi d'autre
disons les invertébrés ou aussi cette
parfois fâcheuse habitude de venir se
nourrir sur les cadavres et de créer des
perforations on va le voir après
et les êtres humains également ont une
grande tradition de perforer tout ce qui
bouge
d'autres d'abord pour en faire des
colliers mais ça on va pas trop en
parler parce que c'est des phénomènes
beaucoup plus récents nous on n'a pas ça
nous intéresse pas
ok donc par exemple l'écart d'Ivoire ils
peuvent créer des traces assez
caractéristiques qu'on appelle les
crushts ou qui sont en gros des cupules
d'écrasement
c'est en fait tout simplement le
résultat
de la pression de la câline
sur la surface de l'os qui va venir
créer cette petite zone circulaire
d'écrasement en son milieu voilà quand
elle est toute ronde comme ça ça c'est
joli
ça ça résulte d'une canine quand elle
est plus allongée bon ici c'est un peu
difficile à dire
quand elle est un peu plus allongée et
plus fine
c'est souvent plutôt le résultat du
danger plutôt molaire prémolaire
plutôt près de
OK
les avertébrés eux c'est un peu la fête
les invertébrés on commence seulement à
s'intéresser un peu aux traces
d'invertébrés c'est un peu le bazar il y
a eu beaucoup plus de travaux en
médecine légale qu'en archéologie pour
les avertébrés
nous on a encore pour le moment un peu à
l'aveugle pour les invertébrés
il y a eu quelques travaux sur l'impact
des termites les termites c'est c'est
monstrueux c'est ce que vous avez là
tout ça là
c'est termites les termites eux elles
creuse leur terre litière ok s'il y a un
sur leur chemin c'est pas un problème
elle continue elle continue de creuser
gaie font des trous tout simplement
ce que vous voyez ici
c'est une trace caractéristique des
termites qui sont ce qui a été défini
comme les traces en d'étoiles tout ça là
en fait c'est les traces des petites
crocs bandiculaires des thermiques qui
vont venir grignoter l'os
voilà ce que vous avez là aussi
donc elle elles vont venir ouais
gratter
grattez l'os creusez l'os tout ça on a
également eu pendant plusieurs années
et moi de même
penser qu'une certaine famille des
insectes les terres cités
c'est ce que vous avez là c'est un petit
coléoptère
était à l'origine de nombreuses
modifications dans le registre fossile
notamment par leur proportion à venir
coloniser un cadavre relativement tôt
dans son processus de décomposition de
décomposition
notamment parce qu'en fait elles
viennent là
bestiole pour pondant pour pondre leurs
œufs mais avant en fait creuser l'os
pondre des larmes dans l'os qu'on va
appeler les chambres de pub passion
et ensuite c'est l'arbre vont se servir
des nutriments et notamment du calcium
contenu autour de leur
de leur plus pape pour développer leur
exosquelette
OK
ça
c'est souvent été retrouvé dans
la littérature scientifique alors que
logique
aujourd'hui on arrive à un moment où en
fait
on fait face aux données actuelles qui
démontrent que en fait les dermests ont
une proportion assez limitée
impacter les
ossements donc on se demande encore d'où
proviennent
toute cette variabilité de traces
attribuée aux invertébrés dans le
registre archéologique
ça ça va encore demander pas mal
d'années d'investigation je pense pour
essayer de faire un peu le tour de
la variabilité des alertes
et on a bien sûr oui
les les
êtres humains les Hominines qui peuvent
créer des semblants de marques ou de
perforation à cause de la percussion
voilà
les marques linéaires ça c'est un des
plus importants et des plus intéressants
pour nous
un des premiers cas qui peut créer des
des marques linéaires assez évidentes
sur les fossiles ce sont les rongeurs et
en Afrique et pour le pays au pistocène
en particulier ce sont les porc-épics
les porc-épic eux
pareil ça peut être éclate ils peuvent
exploser un os assez facilement pour se
faire les dents
c'est les traces qu'on voit ici donc
c'est assez caractéristique parce que en
fait ça va créer deux
[Musique]
sillons plats qui sont en fait les
traces des incisives qui vont se coller
comme ça
on est en retard on en reparle encore et
toujours les insectes les invertébrés
ils peuvent également créer des
marques linéaires
audontoternès donc ce sont les termites
[Musique]
voilà le genre de dessin qui peuvent
créer on a ici l'observation de termites
de termites qui sont en train de se
nourrir sur un crâne de koudou
voilà donc ça c'était au Zimbabwe
au milieu d'un
d'une savane arbustive
crâne de koudou qui est là
et les termites elles elles se
nourrissent de ça
ensuite on a
certains taxons qui sont même pas qui
sont même pas
identifiés mais d'autres par exemple
comme afro burgus du coup afroborghus
c'est c'est aussi un coléoptère qui va
créer ce genre de trace
voilà
pas trop rester non plus s'attarder
là-dessus
les marques de piétinement parce qu'en
fait lors du piétinement peut bien sûr
avoir fracturation il peut y avoir
perforation il peut y avoir des
placements il peut y avoir tout un tas
de phénomènes mais le phénomène qui est
souvent associé au
processus de piétinement ça va être
plutôt
des traces linéaires qui sont dus en
fait au frottement
des grains de quartz pour forcer le
quartz c'est souvent du quartz à la
surface de l'os et qui va venir le rayer
de manière assez chaotique c'est comme
ça de qu'on va réussir à l'identifier le
piétinement vous voyez
là vous avez plusieurs cas ici de
phénomènes de piéton
qui sont en fait aléatoires quoi il y en
a dans tous les sens un peu partout
les traces de de Racine parce qu'en fait
les racines des plantes elles vont aussi
pouvoir venir s'y est creuse dans le
dans le dans le sol
elles peuvent très bien tomber sur un
fossile ou un ossement et elles peuvent
se fixer dessus comme c'est le cas ici
de ce magnifique craque là d'être humain
ou ça s'est fixé dessus voilà elles
peuvent carrément venir creuser et
ronger l'os comme ici de manière un peu
plus intensive
ils peuvent dire le perforé
ok
les traces de crocs carnivores en plus
de perforer j'ai repris exactement la
même photo ici de la petite perforation
de caddie ici elle est également
associée à des traces linéaires
caractéristiques de carnivore qui sont
en fait en général assez profondes assez
courte
orientation préférentielle
une forme en U et voilà donc ça c'est
assez caractéristique des carnivores
et enfin nous ce qui nous intéresse le
plus quand on travaille sur essayer
d'identifier l'origine de la
consommation de la viande et de la
chasse ce sont les traces de boucherie
et en particulier les traces de découpe
qui sont en fait le résultat de la
découpe de la viande ou de la
désarticulation de l'animal ou
du dépouillement peu importe
décharnement dépouillant des
articulations
elles sont assez caractéristiques
ici vous avez tous les caractéristiques
d'une belle trace de découpe
qui sont en fait voilà
[Musique]
une section en vissymétrique la présence
de micro striation interne
décoderziens qui ont été définis comme
ça les conneriens qui sont en fait des
des
microsclés le long de
le long de la street
l'effet des poils
on peut voir ici est en fait
une toute petite
incision secondaire et mineur à la
décision principale
voilà et c'est en étudiant l'orientation
la forme et la localisation de ces
traces le
leur distribution
le long des squelettes de nos
assemblages archéologiques qu'on va être
en mesure d'en tirer des conclusions
sur leur comportement subsistance
ok par exemple ici on a
un schéma assez simple
des opérations bouchères
attendues lors de la découpe d'une
carcasse qui est complète on va tout
d'abord avoir
le dépouillement c'est à dire
la récupération de la peau
ça on attend à avoir des traces
courtes et profondes
parce qu'il faut en général couper les
tendons avec et les attaches musculaires
ça c'est dur faut passer à travers tout
ça donc en général ça laisse des traces
courtes profondes à la surface des eaux
à des endroits stratégiques qui sont en
fait des endroits où c'est plus facile
de de devenir retirer la peau donc ça va
être par exemple à la base
du crad et des cordes je sais pour les
bovidés ça marche pour les cervidés
aussi
sur la mandibule
mais aussi à la base des pâtes comme ça
c'est plus facile pour retirer ensuite
on a la des articulations donc c'est la
mise en pièce de l'animal donc là pour
la mise en pièce pareil on va avoir des
endroits stratégiques
qui vont en fait
définir les grands quartiers de l'animal
voilà on va par exemple des articuler la
mandibule du crabe
et le crâne de la colonne vertébrale
notamment pour avoir accès à la boîte
crânienne et pouvoir récupérer la langue
et le cerveau parce que voilà ce sont
des organes qui se consomment et qui
sont assez riches
on va ensuite ben voilà
veut dire découper tout le squelette
axial en tronçon et ensuite venir
découper tous les membres donc le
squelette appendiculaire pareil en beau
morceaux se faire un petit gigot tout ça
quoi
ensuite bien sûr on a le décharnement
donc le retrait de la viande et le
retrait de la viande bah ça on le
retrouve principalement bah là où il y a
de la viande donc c'est pour ça qu'on va
retrouver beaucoup de street de
décharnement le long des côtes et le
long
humérus fémur radio Ulda tibia parce que
c'est là où on a beaucoup de viande
tout simplement
et ensuite on peut avoir l'extraction de
la moelle
osseuse à l'intérieur pour ça on percute
OK
donc voilà un peu toute la toutes les
familles très rapidement des
modifications de surface osseuse et
c'est pour ça que on ne le répète jamais
assez mais dans une étude archéologique
il est nécessaire de prendre en compte
non pas que les pauvres fossiles qu'on
peut identifier mais aussi toutes les
petites bouillettes et tous les petits
fossiles même qu'on n'est pas capable
d'identifier tous les fragments d'os il
faut les intégrer à l'étude taphonomique
parce qu'ils peuvent nous en apprendre
beaucoup sur l'histoire du dépôt et de
l'assemblage
comment on met en place toutes ces
méthodes bon voilà juste un petit tour
rapide des équipements le basique le
commun à tous c'est une petite loupe à
main très pratique tu es sur le terrain
tu regardes hop
un
caliper un
coulisse un pied à coulisse pour mesurer
tous vos fossiles si vous avez besoin
etc
et la vidéo populaire bah la binôme
labino qui est ici
ça c'est nécessaire pour prendre vos
photos faire des belles observations etc
et bien sûr après il y a tout un tas de
d'équipements subsidiaires pas forcément
nécessaire mais qui sont
devenus très très utilisés taponie on va
avoir par exemple des microscopes
USB qui sont plutôt utilisés eux
normalement d'ingénierie en
micro-ingénier du riz ou en médecine
d'où c'est très pratique quand on est
sur le terrain ou quand on est en étude
de collection à l'étranger dans un musée
random etc bon bah
tu sais pas s'ils ont du matériel à
dispo s'ils ont une belle Bineau pour
prendre des belles photos tamenta
dinolite c'est un petit microscope USB
tu branches à ton PC et tu prends des
photos direct sur ton pc en
microscopique quoi
et après tu as tout un tas d'autres
méthodes de microscopie le microscope
électronique à balayage
la tomographie
confocal tout ça donc ça vous permet
modèle 3D
tout un tas de techniques mais bon c'est
pas trop entrer dans les détails
là-dedans
voilà dernière partie qui va être
normalement relativement rapide je dis
ça à chaque
les signatures taphonomiques et les
quicks on va parler un peu de concept
qui sont
qui sont très très importants qui sont
obligatoires à comprendre quand on
commence à faire de la
tout d'abord je vais vous présenter
donc le concept de signature
taphonomique c'est en gros
tous les phénomènes taphonomiques liés à
l'action d'un seul agent d'un signature
propre OK et par exemple chez certains
cardinaux comme les idées on va pouvoir
identifier la signature du dn par
l'association de différentes
caractéristiques par exemple la présence
de ce qu'on appelle les ports les pores
créent de les ossements comme ça donc ça
c'est les deux parties d'un os qui ont
été grignotés et mangés comme ça ça
c'est typique du yen parce qu'en fait
une consomme beaucoup d'os et elle va
aussi raffoler de l'os spongieux qui est
là et en fait elle va venir
grignoter léché sucer cette partie parce
qu'elle est plaide de graisse et voilà
donc elle adore donc elles font ça et ça
quand on est en période un peu pas de
famille mais quand on est en période de
compétition quand on a un peu la dalle
si c'est fait de manière extrême et
intensive ça va créer
ce qu'on appelle des cylindres osseux
c'est à dire il y aura plus cette partie
il y aura plus cette partie on aura plus
qu'un qu'un cylindre bah ça c'est
caractéristique d'ailleurs
la présence également de de
traces de digestion ça la trace les
traces de digestion pareil si elles sont
intensives c'est assez caractéristique
des idées
et aussi la présence de coprolit donc le
coprolyte ce sont des cacas fossilisés
que pro le caca et élite la pierre que
littéralement
une pierre de caca bah ça
ça c'est caractéristiques des hyènes
parce qu'en fait les hyènes consomment
tellement d'ossements que leur
déjections se retrouvent saturées
en carbonate
calcium et ça va aider à la
fossilisation
de leur déjection donc voilà
les fait l'idée eux ils sont un peu plus
durs à identifier en termes de signature
téléphonique en gros on va avoir un
impact assez mineur sur
sur les extrémités des eaux là par
exemple si tout ça c'est un même
assemblage
jamais de la vie vous retrouverez
d'aussi belles extrémités d'Oslon si ça
avait été accumulé par la hyène parce
que la hyène elle elle le serait manger
comme ça et bah pas les faits
les félins vous observez des traces
effectivement des traces de chrome ici
des traces de ouais des traces de
carnivores des traces de consommation
mais
minime pas intensif comme on peut le
voir chez la hyène
voilà il y a moins de variabilité c'est
moins intensif et il y a souvent peu ou
pas
de fracture de l'os ce qui est pas le
cas de la hyène qui elle est une
grosse destructrice des eaux elle va les
casser les fracturer etc
par exemple on le voit très bien il y a
des traces de consommation de carnivores
ici donc ça c'est des fossiles qui
proviennent dans le duvaï d'Afrique de
l'Est
1,4 1,8 millions d'années
vous avez des traces ici de carnivores
ici vous avez clairement une fracture
qui est d'ordre
poste des positionnel après le dépôt
c'est une fracture qui a eu lieu sur un
os qui était sec
vous voyez il est tout et tout
voilà c'est tout carré il y a pas une
colonne comme on dit voilà c'est c'est
ça quoi c'est tout carré il y a pas de
il y a pas de jolis de jolis fracture
bien
bien lisse bien clair qui sont en
général associés à une fracture sur
frais donc ça veut dire que cet OS a été
consommé mais il était encore entier et
il s'est pété ensuite par la suite voilà
donc ça c'est plutôt fait là
les canidés c'est encore plus obscur que
les félins parce qu'on a moins de
données
mais en gros déjà si vous avez beaucoup
de qualité dans votre assemblage c'est
un signe parce qu'en général ils
viennent ils se nourrissent de ce qui
traînent dans les grottes etc
ils sont aussi à l'origine de de
copropite là on va plutôt réussir à les
identifier basé sur la taille après je
suis pas trop spécialiste des
copropolites alors je sais pas mais
je me pose des questions quand même à
savoir est-ce que
c'est si simple de différencier un
coprolit
d'un chacal adulte d'un coprodite d'une
hyène bébé
on peut se poser la question
moi je ne sais pas
il y a un peu de littérature
ça se regarde
j'avoue j'ai pas avant d'enregistrer le
cours là je suis pas renseigné plus que
ça sur sur les coprolits de qualité
et ça existe le savoir ça existe
un peu de un peu de fracture
il y a ce qu'on appelle
l'effondrement des épices donc
l'effondrement des parties
les extrémités des eaux vous voyez ici
ces trucs là impression que ça c'est
écroulé quoi et bah ça c'est différent
de ce qu'on observe chez les félins ou
chez les
et ensuite on peut avoir des eaux
digérer parce que les canidés il le faut
aussi mais moins intensif que les
pour ce qui est des homides comment
identifier la signature téléphonique
entropique une signature anthropique
d'abord ça va être la présence de traces
de boucherie sur les ossements que ce
soit Marc de découpe ou marques de
percussion bien sûr on en a parlé la
liste de fonds de Budo spécifique ça
c'est quelque chose qu'on n'a pas en
général
dans des milieux ouverts et naturels
mais bon ça c'est assez rare le cas des
des faux de mono spécifique
ensuite
un assemblage
osseux qui est caractérisé par une très
très forte fragmentation en tout petit
fragment et tous ces petits fragments
ils ont l'air d'être
frais d'être fracturé
ça c'est quelque chose qu'on va pas voir
chez les carnivores parce que les
carnivores eux ils peuvent très
facilement fracturer les ossements en
particulier les gaines mais ça va créer
des gros éclats ils vont pas faire des
successions de petits éclats frais comme
ça OK
et des eaux bas du facturer bien sûr
comme des outils d'os comme on l'a vu
aswards quand on faisait l'historique
mais aussi d'autres d'autres artefacts
un peu plus rares mais tout aussi
intéressant par exemple en Afrique de
l'Est on a ce cadre d'un biface en os
d'éléphant
1,4 millions d'années sur le site de
conduire d'Éthiopie on a également cette
éclat dans selon qui qui semble à avoir
été
très façonné pour lui donner une forme
de
barbelés
qui est un terme pour plus
définir la forme mais si on voudrait
définir sa fonction bien sûr ce serait
un harpon ça c'est un million d'années
mais les auteurs ne sont pas du tout
définitifs sur l'identification de cet
objet on est même pas sûr que ce soit un
outil en tant que tel parce qu'il est
tellement unique cet objet que
bon on ne sait pas et comme vous voyez
il est assez mal conservé
donc assez difficile de voir des traces
de façonnage dessus s'il y en a
et bien sûr toutes ces
indices à phonomiques de présence
humaine si elles sont supportées par la
présence d'os Dominique mais aussi
d'outils en pierre dans l'assemblage bon
bah là c'est déjà un bon d'ensemble de
[Musique]
preuves de la présence des hommes
et de leur rôle dans l'origine
l'accumulation OK
mais tout ça c'est bien beau mais notre
problème à nous c'est ce qu'on appelle
les cuisinalité qu'est-ce que c'est les
cuisinalités c'est
un concept
qui tend à dire que
différents agents téléphoniques peuvent
parfois produire la même signature
et à l'inverse
différentes signatures
peuvent être produit par un seul et même
agent
face à existent et c'est un problème
pour nous en fait par exemple
c'est surtout vrai
pour la représentation squelettique
par exemple
admettons vous avez un assemblage osseux
avec plein de juvéniles plein de
petites antilopes
quelques adultes
vous vous retrouvez avec un assemblage
ou biaisé où tous vos juvéniles ont
disparu et il ne vous reste plus que vos
quelques adultes vous le savez pas qu'il
y avait tous les juvénients
il a disparition de tous ces juvéniles
elle peut être du à plusieurs choses ça
peut être dû à l'action des hyèdes
l'action des hyènes elle peut par
exemple avoir mangé et digérer tous les
os un peu fragiles vous avez plus rien
ça peut être l'action de l'eau
l'eau est venu
à balayer les ossements qui étaient sur
le sol de votre site et tous les et tous
les ossements les moins denses les avec
le plus haut coefficient de flottaison
ils vont partir
tous les ossements juridiques
date deux phénomènes et deux agents
différents savoir la hyène et l'eau vous
vous créez un profil de mortalité
équivalent à savoir une
sur-représentation d'individu adulte et
aucun juillet
voilà ça c'est un problème pour nous
c'est également le cas bon bah pour la
représentation squelettique
très compliqué la représentation
squelettique parce que bah c'est un peu
comme l'exemple que j'ai pris là
plusieurs phénomènes peuvent amener à la
disparition des mêmes éléments
squelettiques s'ils sont fragiles ils
sont fragiles et peu importe si c'est un
carnivore ou si c'est l'eau ou si c'est
autre chose ça disparaît voilà et ça
impossible pour vous de dire d'où tout
proviendrait
potentiellement
ce biais quoi à la limite si vous voyez
que tout votre assemblage il y a plein
de manganèse c'est tout poli plein
d'actions de l'eau
plein d'actions d'eau
et que vous avez que des adultes et et
une grosse un gros gros pieds identifié
dans votre présentation ce qu'elle
éthique à savoir
les ossements les plus denses sont les
plus représentés bah là vous pouvez
potentiellement et mettre l'hypothèse
que c'est l'eau le facteur qui est à
l'origine
de votre pied OK
et enfin pour les modifications de
surface bah là pareil c'est un problème
par exemple on a le problème depuis des
années pour le helting versus scaretic
pour l'identification des plus anciennes
traces de découpes du monde à savoir
celle de Tiki car 3,4 millions d'années
où certaines d'esprits observées à la
surface de ces fossiles ont été
identifiés comme des traces de
piétinement par certains autres
chercheurs et ça c'est à cause de la
similarité de certaines traces de
piétinant avec des traces de découpe
certains phénomènes de piétine
piétinement peuvent amener à guider
à
ouais mais
[Musique]
les traces de découpe et là vous avez
l'exemple ici au milieu ce qui est censé
être en théorie une trace de découpe
ultra une véritable trace de découpe à
gauche et une trace de piétinement à
droite et là vous voyez un problème
parce que
les deux possèdent des caractéristiques
à la fois de marques de découpe mais
aussi à la fois de piétine
sur la trace de découpe ici vous avez
les coderdiens
le shoulder effect même s'il est pas
très clair ici
par contre
sur la portion en tout cas de marque
qu'on voit ici
vous avez pas de micro striation interne
et vous n'avez pas
de micro marche
alors qu'à l'inverse sur la trace qui
avait été créée
et des micro
usure les microstriations internes
bon là la photo de la du piétinement
elle est prise on a l'impression
vraiment d'un plan horizontal vous
n'aurez aimé avoir une vue un peu plus
un peu plus oblique parce que là en fait
on a du mal à voir la section
de la marque est-ce qu'elle est vraiment
en vissymétrique ou pas là vu du dessus
comme ça on dirait franchement qu'elle
est toute carrée qu'elle a un bord plat
qu'elle a un fond tout plat
ça c'est assez caractéristique et après
bon bah il y a d'autres caractéristiques
qui vont nous aider au diagnostic
parce que là ok c'est une vue très
rapprochée au microscope électronique à
balayage bon bah on voit rien mais si
par contre la street boucherie elle est
située
au niveau de l'insertion d'un tendon
qu'elle a la bonne orientation et la
pomme morphologie bon bah là déjà ça
aide
et si sur l'ossement sur lequel vous
avez cette stri de piétinement vous avez
partout sur l'os
d'esprits qui vont dans tous les sens
qui ont des morphologies qui varient à
droite à gauche bon ben c'est du pied de
bon voilà ce que je veux dire il faut
toujours utiliser
ce qu'on appelle un faisceau d'arguments
dans ta phonomie pour arriver à
l'hypothèse la plus parcimonieuse il est
en aucun cas possible d'utiliser un seul
élément
pour identifier l'origine d'un processus
ou d'un agent ou peu importe ok que ce
soit au niveau de l'individu du spécimen
de lancement ou même au niveau du site
et de l'accumulation de votre dépôt
voilà donc c'est ce que je vous disais
vous avez besoin d'un faisceau
d'arguments cluster of evidence pour
bien quantifier
l'action et la contribution de ces
différents agents et processus au sein
de l'histoire de votre assemblage et
pour ça il va falloir
être capable de mobiliser toutes les
observations et de les que vous avez
obtenu et de les faire fonctionner
ensemble que ce soit à partir de
l'observation de votre liste de faune
mais aussi de la représentation
squelettique des profils de mortalité
bien sûr des modifications de surface
osseuse et ensuite du tout de tout le
contexte
la présence d'artefact archéologique
biologique votre contexte de votre
contexte sédimentaire votre contexte
chronologique
et ensuite surtout ne jamais délaisser
vos esquives car dans vos esquis se
cachent
probablement le secret de l'histoire ta
phonomique de votre assemblage
voilà donc là j'ai fini pour cette
partie de vidéo
on va reprendre pour la deuxième partie
où là je vous présenterai
certains exemples
d'études ta phonomie qui ont été
effectuées ces dernières années et pour
lequel il y a de bas ou pas je vais vous
présenter certains cartes à phonomique
assez intéressant qui sont pas forcément
liés à un débat mais les plus importants
d'entre eux sont liés à un débat qui a
des débats qui ont toujours été
discussions qui ont toujours lieu à
l'heure actuelle des débats qui sont
parfois assez véhément dans la
communauté scientifique
et on va essayer de voir pourquoi dans
la deuxième partie de vidéo voilà donc
si vous êtes arrivé jusqu'ici bravo
félicitations et merci à vous d'avoir
écouté la première partie de ce cours
sur l'introduction
à la tafonie
sociale d'Afrique et merci encore à
Julien Benoît pour cette opportunité et
je vous retrouve pour la deuxième partie
de cette vidéo